welcome to fake gurus number five today
we're talking about the winning stock
coach aka Michael Matthew and the reason
we're talking about Michael Matthew is
look I want to share with you guys what
he's all about I think he's really an
interesting case study that we could
learn a lot from so let's talk about him
this is sort of the outline sort of the
outline of what we're talking about
today so the first thing I want to talk
to you guys about is he is the owner of
winning stock coach now winning stock
coach here winning stock coach is a
website that is unfortunately no longer
available but exists on the internet in
the form of a series of webinars by
Michael Matthew himself and we'll get
into why he doesn't have a website
anymore in a second but basically he was
teaching how to do charts my chart
analysis like a lot of stock gurus on
the internet do right now so he would he
would do market overviews he would he
would teach you like techniques that he
had he would do position recaps and he
would do he would do all these things
like try to try to teach people how to
invest all these kind of things and you
see it break the ice inning triangle and
every time it does you see this big
volume spike and then typically what you
do is that next candle you see it kind
of hanging out where did you run up to
here so you get the idea pretty pretty
standard stuff a lot of people on the
internet are doing this kind of like
chart analysis the other thing I wanted
to mention is that he has very positive
earth views so I picked a few of my my
favorites I've been with winning stock
coach for a little over a year but prior
to this service I'd never traded or knew
anything I've said the last year
studying learning blah blah blah he's
talking about all his growth all this
stuff he says it's amazing he's got a
passion to teach whatever great review
right and then we've got only
educational service this is the service
for you for people who want to learn
stocks who want to who want to want to
learn to fish and not just be fed okay
so yada yada yada telling you how great
he is then we've also got this one
incredible after extremes up its ups and
downs on my own and other things that do
the run-and-shoot method of trading it's
been a breath of
fresh air and maybe a complete save to
feel like I really can learn how to
trade and not just trade what others are
picking for me coach Mike and mods are
always willing to work out the kinks oh
so coach mike has pretty incredible
reviews and also on his Angie's List
he's got an A rating a rating on Angie's
List this is a current rating on his
site winning stock coach ok great
reviews he's got a live trade trading
with a chat room and then he's also he
posts his track record of winning
statements now all these things all
these things sound great right this
sounds good it sounds it sounds as good
as any standard guru that you might see
now let's let's talk about the only
problem though the OTP as they call it
the only problem the only problem with
all Michael Matthew is he doesn't trade
anymore and if you want to know why he
doesn't trade anymore we just have to go
to this where Michael Matthew was
sentenced to 20 years for fraud
[Music]
why was he sentenced to 20 years for
fraud after all those good reviews after
all those great reviews well he took
nearly half a million dollars from
people who wanted to make secure
investments through his company now what
a shock right now if you've been
following me and you have some of my
intuition you might have known this guy
was a fraud when he starts promising
things like a like a according to this
guy he promises a 147 million he made
147 million dollars last year and
according to this coach Mike gets 400%
gains in as little as one day so if
you've been following me for a while
I've been telling you guys that that is
impossible that those kind of whenever
someone promises ridiculous gains there
there's probably something else going on
behind the scenes and that was certainly
the case here according to he says he's
very sorry he's he's very sorry that he
stole however half a million dollars
from people
and the judge says I'm not sure what
you're sorry for because he didn't seem
sorry but when he was taking everyone's
money he got charged with 36 felonies
related to theft and securities fraud
and was ordered to pay half a million
dollars in restitution okay here's what
I want to draw your attention to he had
convinced people he was a successful
trader and could get them large returns
on investments from 2014 to 2016 that's
what he ran the site and whatever
remorse he did manifest wasn't manifest
until he was arrested it's as fake as
the statements he provided to his
investors
so unlike Ricky Gutierrez this guy
actually provided statements to its
investors but of course when you're
claiming those kind of crazy returns
there they're bound to be forged and
that was the case with with this guy and
and the thing that I want to point out
is if you were there before he got
charged with these things there were so
many people that were positive that this
guy was legit as you saw from those
reviews people were positive that he was
nothing but legit he was some financial
wizard some financial guru had figured
out secrets that no one else had access
to and of course that was not the case
and in fact let's see here and then in
fact how he got the returns he did was
he took their money the people's money
who put it put it in his investment
group and spent out himself and covered
thousands of dollars in losses on his
etrade account so he was actually a bad
trader when he was trading on each trade
he was losing money and he kept covering
it with the losses of people who thought
it was a guru and saw his account
balance just keep going up little do
they know when they put money with him
it was just dumping into his invest his
trading account and so they kept seeing
it go up but they didn't realize it was
because people believed in him and put
money into his his scheme now there are
a lot of different ways for schemes to
happen not everybody has put as an
investment group some people sell
courses some people just want like Fame
and so they just promise ridiculous
returns but you've got to realize if
it's too good to be true it probably is
now the SEC all these people who
investigate these things don't have time
to investigate every single one so there
are plenty of people out there who
haven't we haven't had time to
officially debunk it kind of like call
to task on what they're claiming and and
these guys have also gotten more
sophisticated with the lies but you've
got to realize that when these when
these people come out with these crazy
claims you've got to be skeptical I mean
the real thing I want to want to make
you think about is is what was the only
thing that what gave away Mike when he
was when he was a you know when he was
pulling off the scheme the only thing
that gave away Mike that that you could
have figured out for sure that he was
cheating people at the time was his
insane returns because he apparently had
put in get given investor reports to
people to prove what he was making but
those turned out to be lies but you
didn't know at the time he also had a
live trading platform with his chat room
that people swore up and down where he
posted his wins and losses so you
couldn't have figured out that way you
couldn't have figured out with his
reviews cuz everyone's saying he's great
he calls himself a guru so the only way
you know that this guy's a liar and is
taking your money is by just evaluating
his claims evaluating what he's saying
he's making and say okay what do I know
about people who actually trade on Wall
Street what do I know about the average
performance of hedge funds
underperforming the the the average
indicee what do I know about Warren
Buffett winning the ten year bet against
hedge funds where hedge funds couldn't
outperform stock market indexes when you
see somebody who claims consistent
returns who claims to be making insane
returns you should naturally wonder
what's going on in here don't just
accept their claims at face value don't
wait till the person has to go to jail
for you to realize what's going on so
that's pretty much it I just wanted to
expose you got guys to this person and
the other thing I want to get you
thinking about is like look he stole
half a million dollars and look how many
subscribers he has okay this guy was not
popular he had let's see two hundred
sixty two subscribers forty thousand
views now I don't know what is his
facebook presence is like I mean I guess
we can check on Twitter he had 1,900
followers on Facebook
it looks like his pages expired in other
words he wasn't that popular and but
because people are so desperate people
sunk half a million dollars into his his
fake scheme so just think how about
those people who have successful
channels what about those people with
successful channels how much money do
you think they're taking from people now
I'm again I can only evaluate the
criminality of somebody who's actually
been you know convicted but just think
about the analogy I mean how many people
also have supposedly a track record of
winning how many people have a live
trading live trading floor with the
chatroom how many of them have a bunch
of positive reviews how many of them say
there's some financial guru who can
teach you how to trade how many of them
offer free free trading lessons that
look something like this how many of
them I mean I bet you can think of a few
and how many of them only have one thing
that looks sketchy and that's what they
say they're supposedly making don't
believe it guys don't believe the hype
okay stick with some fundamentals don't
read people who are making their money
from courses from from people from
people who are promising you money if
you invest in their investment group
which supposedly has amazing returns
don't buy into this stuff and if you
have a tip about a fake guru send it to
my email address but here's the thing
actually have a tip so people like say
like please review X but they don't have
any reason that the person is an actual
fake guru if you're gonna contact me
make sure you have some kind of evidence
or some smoking gun and maybe you're
featured on the next fake guru I'm
obliged to all the tips so I hope you
enjoyed this episode of fake gurus and
the
amen listen to the McCord space and him
from straight smacking of the war I was
on the plane and the stewardess said
that's foolishness so for that beat I
came
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]